the mainstream media events their daddy
issues by baselessly smearing teenagers
from Covington high school we will
analyze the leftist character assassins
and the quasi conservatives who aided
and abetted the slander then to make two
contrived leftist and non traverses in
two days the media sail our very own Ben
Shapiro for refusing to murder a baby
finally Martin Luther King goes to the
mountaintop I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
this Covington high school story what
the media and the left and a lot of
conservatives in the Catholic Church and
what just about everybody has done to
these kids who were wearing Magga hats
and minding their own business in
Washington DC is the most disturbing
story that I have seen in a very long
time we will go through it point by
point but first let's make a little bit
of money honey with joy bird have you
heard about the revolution in online
furniture shopping and joy bird the
company behind it all joy bird is
wonderful joy bird believes that you
should never settle when it comes to
your home furnishings and that you
should always have the freedom to be
boldly original I love joy bird I have
this beautiful chair from joy bird in a
very cool green color I can't quite
describe it I don't know it reminds me
of home it reminds me of the East Coast
I just had my in-laws in over the
weekend and so you know you want to have
the apartment looking nice and
everything and they both complement
complement to this chair it is super
nice and I have joy bird to thank for it
you can turn your ideas into reality
with hundreds of styles and options for
mid-century modern to contemporary
classics they are customizable in an
amazing array of fabric choices from
rich buttery leather and plush Velvets
to every color imaginable wide range of
kid and pet friendly upholstery options
available when I got my furniture when I
got this nice chair I of course
instantly spilled something on it and I
was I was very lucky that the fabric was
fairly resistant to the liquid I was
able to get it out very quickly just
fabulous furniture see how joy bird is
revolutionising online furniture
shopping if you don't love your joy bird
return it for a full refund but you
won't want to free returns within two
weeks of delivery create the furniture
that brings you joy today at joy bird
comm /m k s that is joy bird comm / MK s
and receive an exclusive offer for 25%
off your first order by using the code M
K s let's get right into this non
traverse ease abounding and the child
abuse that occurred at the hands of the
media at the hands of the Catholic
Church at the hands of many conservative
pundits at the hands of politicians at
the hands of this Native American
charlatan nathan phillips at the hands
of the black is realized
which we'll get to in a second there
this wacky black supremacist group that
coincidentally I've actually spent a
fair bit of time speaking to in person
during my times in New York and DC the
the child abuse that went around at the
hands of these people is absolutely
repulsive it was the biggest Twitter
pile on mob that I had seen since Friday
when they tried to do it to Ben here is
the viral clip that everybody was
reacting to just to give you some
context you can see in this play what
you can see in this clip is this kid is
staring at this Native American fellow
who's banging a drum right in the kid's
face inches from his face and the kid
there is just sort of smiling in a
bemused way a lot of the kids in the
background are just standing around not
doing anything a couple of them are kind
of popping around to the drumbeat and
that's that's about it some of them are
wearing make America great again hats
and that's it the kid has just got to
sort of amused look on his face now I've
been to a ton of political rallies I
have been there as an as a political
campaign aide I've been there as
covering the rallies I've been there
getting common I've been there as a
speaker where there have been protests
or whatever when people come up to you
when crazy people come up to you with
drums yelling in your face anything you
do can be portrayed as wrong if you get
in his face that's portrayed as wrong if
you push him away from you
that's portrayed is wrong if you're
frowning that looks a little strange so
one of one of the only ways to react is
to sort of have a bemused look on your
face that shows that you have a bit of a
sense of humor about politics that clip
goes around all of a sudden people lose
their minds over this there risa a slant
he's a cannibal from CNN I don't mean
this in a hyperbolic way he is a
cannibal he ate human brains one time
and then talked about it on television
he is a CNN contributor he said that he
had never seen a more punchable face
than this kid and then how old is the
kid 16 or something I don't even know
how old he is he says he really that's
the most punchable face I've ever seen
because recess Lane isn't ever
to the mirror so he doesn't I guess
thank that kid was number one for him
immediately on Twitter uber facts puts
up a tweet they say a group of students
from Covington Catholic High School were
mocking Nathan Phillips that's the
Indian guy a Vietnam veteran as he was
singing the Ames song during the
indigenous peoples March doesn't matter
what side of the aisle you're on this is
unacceptable and then that's what
everyone starts pylians unacceptable so
the first question when you see that
real clip the the viral clip is how did
this start okay so all we see is this
Indian guy in this mag akid face-to-face
and the and the Indian guy banging a
drum right in the kid's face you say how
did this start was the Indian guy there
minding his own business banging his
drum doing whatever and then all the
kids swarmed around him and this maggot
kid gets right in his face is that what
happened or where the kids minding their
own business and then the Indian guy
comes up and gets in their face it's
unclear so you want to know what exactly
happened I'll show you the fuller video
in a second but to show you how this
goes all around the world have ally gets
around the world before the truth can
put its pants on here is just one story
from just CNN everyone else covered this
to just CNN the anatomy of a fake news
story here's how they open it we are
hearing from a Native American elder in
Vietnam war veteran speaking to CNN
after a disturbing viral video shows a
group of teens harassing and mocking him
in the nation's capital
and this was on Friday on the steps of
the Lincoln Memorial when he saw a clash
of RuPt in between a group of teenage
students okay
so just the viral clip I'm not even
saying unfortunately for these fake news
people for this charlatan Indian elder
whatever Nathan Phillips and for the
black Israelite black supremacist so
unfortunately and for the fake news
unfortunately for them other people took
video see they didn't think that the
whole video would ever come out so they
could have pushed their narrative but
even from just that clip that was going
around do you see the kids taunting the
Native American man what is he oh is he
taunting actually the thing that the kid
is being criticized for is for not doing
anything he doesn't say anything he
doesn't
move he doesn't do anything he's
standing there doing nothing with a
bemused look on his face well some
lunatic named Nathan Phillip starts
banging a drum in his face let me tell
you something I'm a very peaceable guy
I'm a very nice guy if somebody starts
banging a drum in my face he will not be
banging it for very long I would not
have the restraint to stand there while
some guy is banging some stupid
instrument in my face uninvited this kid
showed remarkable restraint remarkable
respect for his elders would that we all
had that sort of reverence and and that
sort of wherewithal not to do it how was
it portrayed on CNN
I don't know that woman's name on CNN if
I would I would love to say her name on
the air to shame her for what was a
truly shameful segment she says they
were taunting him show me the taunting
where's the taunting didn't anybody get
me a photo of the taunting a clip of the
taunting I don't think so
also where is this where is this taking
place what are the circumstances she
doesn't say she's saying that he there
they're mocking him they're assaulting
him where does it begin we'll see that
in just one second then she goes on
Friday
steps of the Lincoln Memorial when he
saw a clash of RuPt in between a group
of teenage students and four
african-american young men preaching
about the Bible and oppression for
African American young men preaching
about the Bible and oppression so now
we've got three groups we've got the
teenagers who are there wearing
megawhatts waiting for their bus there
by the lincoln memorial waiting for
their bus to come you've got this Indian
guy who's banging a drum in the kids
face you then have this third group just
introduced which are called the black
Israelites or the Hebrew is realized
they have a few different terms they use
these are guys who I ran into in New
York years ago and I actually got into a
long conversation with them they think
that whites are the devil they hate the
Jews they hate everyone but black people
and they think that the blacks or the
real Jews so the Jews are not the Jews
they're the fake Jews and the blacks are
the Jews they're the real descendants of
the tribes of Israel there are not very
many of these guys I actually get kind
of a kick out of them because they're
spewing this vile racist hatred but then
you talk to them and they they're
they're like kind of funny in this
quaint they're like a throwback to this
era
that is gone this era of kind of crazy
in awful race relations that thankfully
has been neutered and thankfully we
don't really have that anymore so the I
think there are about 20,000 of these
guys in the whole country so when you
see them you just sort of think huh
thank goodness we don't have that
anymore thank goodness they're not more
widespread and so I have actually talked
to these guys at length and I said what
you don't like me because I'm a white
guy they say well the white people are
the devil's white people are awful I
said why you seem to like me I don't
know I'm a nice enough guy they said
well where are you from I said I don't
know I'm half English and half Sicilian
it was all Sicilian that's fine that
means you're descended from the Moors
that's okay you're African don't worry
you're okay
you're my fratello so okay that's fine
so there Caillou no there these guys are
just lunatics who stand in the street
and spout this this awful racial
rhetoric there they're mocking these
kids they're calling them a slur for gay
people they're calling them incest
babies they're mocking a black kid who
went to this high school who was with
the group they're saying they were
saying that the white kids from the
school we're gonna steal the black kids
organs I don't they're just lunatics I
mean they're just crazy people that you
see in DC in New York so the one thing
they don't do is preach about the Bible
here's just an example of what they say
with that racist garbage oh look at
these dirty crap paint standing the damn
stuff for five minutes
when's the last time you ever seen a
Mexican or Hispanic or Native American
or Negro shoot up a school
yeah crickets crickets crickets crickets
that's right
look at it scatter it all for that they
scatter it all for that Hey going off
for that is one of mommy's dirty and
sick gum that's right had a sin and
report that for young african-american
men preaching about the Bible that's as
CNN reports on the black Israelites so
now you have to ask are the people at
CNN the stupidest people on the face of
the earth totally ignorant of anything
or are they liars spoiler alert they're
liars that's what they are they're liars
this segment was slander it was
defamation these kids should sue them
for everything they're worth it was
horrific it goes on don't worry we have
a lot more but first let me just check
in on my time it's time to thank
movement our wonderful sponsor movement
watches founded on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank they've sold
almost 2 million watches worldwide by
bringing quality designs at fair prices
I gave one of these to my dad for
Christmas he loves it I love mine I get
compliments on it all the time I wear
the Atlas revolver they have a ton of
great stuff though and they always have
new designs coming in I always want the
new design but I haven't gotten it yet
the one I really like is the ark they
have a new automatic watch so it's not a
battery-powered watch it's automatic
movement really stylish I love it I just
love the products they look really good
this was a crowdfunded startup it was
started by college dropouts and now it's
one of the biggest watch companies in
the world they start at just 95 bucks if
you were in a department store you could
pay four or five hundred bucks maybe
more for the for the automatic watches
mechanical watches they have clean
design it's really minimalist really
high-quality products and you can get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
cough fa ce o VF e fe movement is
launching new styles on
your site all the time checking out an
MV MT comm / co FFA Co V Fe Fe enjoying
the movement so CN n now you've already
seen how dishonest this is they refer to
these guys who are calling the white
kids animals calling them slurs for
homosexuals call Youm all these awful
things
incest babies they refer to them as
african-american men preaching about the
Bible as no Osama bin Laden he was just
a Middle Eastern man preaching about the
Quran you know Adolf Hitler was just a
just a German fellow preaching about
Government Reform wasn't he
well we're talking about rather
different things so it actually gets
even more dishonest if you can believe
it it goes on when I was there not
standing there and I seen that group of
people in front of me and I seen the
angry faces and and all of that I
realized I had put myself in a really
dangerous situation you know there's
like here's a group of people who were
angry at somebody else and I put myself
in front of that and all of a sudden I'm
the one who's all that anger and all
that wanting to have the freedom to just
rip me apart you know that was scary
that and and I I'm a Vietnam Times
veteran and and I know that mentality of
there's enough of us we can do this okay
so he said he was ripped apart does he
look like he was ripped apart did you
say you saw the video was he being
ripped apart at all I don't think he was
he is he's maybe he could have been
ripped apart by the black Israelites
those guys are pretty tough hombres but
those kids didn't do anything and this
guy Nathan Phillips this charlatan this
liar goes on television and
intentionally lies about these kids he's
not it they're trying to some people are
trying to rehabilitate Nathan Phillips
and the media they say oh maybe he just
misunderstood maybe he was miss
communicating he wasn't miss
communicating anything he's a liar who
went on tell
and slandered these kids and they should
sue the pants off him - they should sue
him and take his drum with them he he
also uses our strange phrase he says I'm
a Vietnam times veteran so I don't know
he's being portrayed as a Vietnam
veteran and if he's a Vietnam veteran
thank you for your service appreciate it
love it whenever anyone goes out and
defends my freedom
that's a strange phrase of Vietnam times
veteran I don't know what that means
also no angry chants also who approached
whom fortunately for us we have the
video and actually it was Nathan
Phillips the Indian guy with the drum
who approached the kids so this is all
being filmed by the black Israelites you
guys that you can hear the black
Israelites in the background because
they're the ones filming
[Music]
here you can see nathan phillips is the
guy leading the charge doing some thing
with his voice and then banging on the
drum walking straight up to the kids
marching up with them with the whole
posse behind him a lot of people filming
it was a total set up and it was a setup
by this lying charlatan named nathan
phillips aided and abetted by the
mainstream media he says at the end of
that clip he says it reminded me of of
the vietnam times this mentality of if
there's enough of us we can do this it's
amazing how self-aware that statement is
because what he's really talking about
is this set up in the sham that he
instigated that was abetted by everybody
else in the media and the conservative
movement the catholic church everybody
to set up these kids to lie about what
they did to try to ruin their lives to
try to get them expelled from school
explicitly and and to and CNN gives him
even more time even more lies phillips
describes the tense moments now being
replayed over and over again online when
a young man got right in his face watch
when I started going forward in that
massive groups of people started
separating in and separating and moving
aside to allow me to move out of the way
or proceed this young feller put himself
in front of me and wouldn't move and so
I could if I took another step I would
be putting my my person into his
presence into his space and I would have
touched him and that would have been the
thing that the group of people would
have needed to spring on me oh wow can
you imagine how vicious and awful these
kids could have been in Nathan Phillips
his imagination can you imagine the
awful crimes they committed in this
lunatics imagination he said that the
kid put himself in Nathan Phillips his
space you just saw Nathan Phillips
leading all of these other guys directly
to the kids
when he targeted the kids exactly went
right up to them it's not that the kid
was in his way and he couldn't get
around him
he marched right at him if the kid had
moved this lunatic probably would have
moved as well and then in his MOT you
see because what the kids did in reality
isn't absolutely nothing other than
stand there and not flinch and smile and
not take the drum which he probably
should have done and thrown it over the
guy's head that's what happened in
reality what happened in Nathan Phillips
his imagination is they were just
waiting to pounce and rip him apart and
it was a total fraud in a lie and CNN
pushed it like like the narratives that
it always does this is how terrifying it
is my main takeaway watching this last
night in horror watching the media pile
on is that Trump was right the fake news
media the media that construct fake
narratives intentionally fake narratives
is the enemy of the people they are the
enemy of the people that's true
certainly near the enemy of those people
they're the enemy of the truth they're
the enemy of justice they're trying to
ruin these little kids lives get them
expelled from school but of course they
weren't the only ones Liz Warren of
course piled on she had to defend her
people Liz Warren tweeted quote Omaha
elder and Vietnam veteran Nathan
Phillips and or hateful taunts with
dignity and strength then urged us all
to do better none of that happened
that's just completely untrue the mayor
of this town where the school is from
Covington the mayor denounced them
immediately
the diocese the Roman Catholic Diocese
of Cummington denounced them immediately
said that what they did was contrary to
Christianity and the teachings of Christ
immediately here's what law redeemer the
spokesman for the Roman Catholic Diocese
of Covington said immediately on a
30-second clip hadn't seen anything said
quote we condemn the actions of the
Covington Catholic High School students
toward Nathan Phillips specifically a
Native Americans in general we extend
our deepest apologies to mr. Phillips
this behavior is opposed to the Church's
teachings on the dignity and respect of
the human person the matter is being
investigated and we will take
appropriate action up to an including
expulsion so she admits in her stupid
statement that she doesn't have any of
the facts because the investigation is
being conducted
they haven't conducted it
they've just responded to a tweet but
they immediately condemned their own
kids their own students and they they
say that this guy Nathan Phillips a
total fraud is is some wonderful man and
they apologized to him despicable
another a Catholic priest James Martin a
Jesuit priest he is a very popular on
social media very left-wing he tweeted
out immediately
again no facts no waiting no reserve
judgment no Who am I to judge that we
always hear from from the our Pope and
and probably from James Martin himself
he says tweet quote I am is disgusted by
the contemptuous laughter of the mass of
students as I am moved by the quiet
dignity of the solitary man who
continues to chant those students could
learn much from this elder if they had
chosen to or if they choose to give me a
break even conservatives even
conservatives piled on the National
Review sent out an article immediately
it said the Covington students might as
well have spit on the cross that was by
Nicholas Frank of itch fortunately
National Review took that piece down
finally they took that piece down when
the new video totally exonerated the
kids Rod Dreher Robbie George a lot of
conservatives came out now fortunately
those conservatives apologized the
difference is the mayor of Covington
hasn't apologized the Diocese of
Covington hasn't apologized
James Martin hasn't apologized there was
an archbishop Archbishop what is his
name
gosh his name escapes me he sent out a I
think is Archbishop of around Louisville
he sent out of tweets condemning the
kids and all that none of them have
apologized and actually what James Mart
father James Martin did was he just
tweeted out he's he went on this rant
this sort of rambling rant about how
there were different perspectives and
you know how can we really know in
different different narratives and then
he says quote this teachable moment can
offer us if we are both open and humble
important lessons about racism and
marginalization about dialogue and
encounter and about truth and
reconciliation during this coming week
which is believe it or not Catholic
schools week he said he would be happy
to apologize
if you know if there's some reason to do
it if it turns out they're good and
moral question Christians he says if
we're open if we're open and humble
enough for the teachable moment the
teachable moment is for you father
Martin you rushed to judgment you in
your haste to tweet condemned a group of
Catholic school students who did
absolutely nothing wrong
and in fact who were the only people who
behaved appropriately and of all of them
out of the Charlatans Indian elder
Nathan Phillips out of the black
Israelites spewing hatred at those
students the only one the only group of
people to behave well were those
students and you father Martin Oh them
an apology and you don't you shouldn't
use mealy-mouthed
platitudes to get out of it and say oh
there were different narratives there
aren't there there are there are two
narratives I guess the one that you
pushed and the truth and you should
apologize for getting it wrong
you should apologize for rushing to
judgment and and you should apologize
for what is actually not a vice unique
to you but was was taken up by all of
the media on the right and the left it
was taken up by politicians which is
this outrageous self-aggrandizement even
at the cost of the truth even at the
cost of the reputation of these kids who
did nothing wrong the actual teachable
moment comes from BuzzFeed BuzzFeed and
Peterson at BuzzFeed to a senior riot
culture writer over there tweeted up I
have watched all the videos you can
understand that the situation was more
complex than the first video and still
recognize why the sight of that face
caused a visceral reaction in so many
the sight of that face she's talking
about the kid and she is admitting the
obvious it's pretty disgusting but she's
admitting the obvious the left holds a
categorical hatred for white men the
sight of that face what's that face it's
the face of a young white man she's not
saying the experience of his character
she's not saying the reading his
thoughts it has not it is purely
physical the sight of that face and the
purely physical characteristics are he's
a young white man and she hates him
because the left hates young white men
they hate them
the left is creating a white racial
consciousness all of us conservatives
left-wingers we talk about how bad that
is
I don't want to politics that is
primarily racial I think that's terrible
the left is creating it Sam Francis the
the columnist predicted this decades ago
he said if the left continues to embrace
leftist politics they're going to create
a white racial consciousness Sam Francis
actually encouraged it to happen
he thought the culture was already too
too far gone to avoid it the left has
created that there were tweets going
around of a juxtaposition between this
kid and in judge Cavanaugh and they said
see it's the say it's just awful it's it
because they hate white guys it's a
really bizarre thing the worst thing you
can be in our intersectional culture is
a white guy according to this ideology
that's the worst thing because they're
the oppressors they're the worst there
are their patriarchs they're the worst
people on the face of the earth that's
the worst thing you could possibly be in
this culture I guess no a straight white
guy would I guess the straight white guy
who thinks it is a male that's the worst
thing according to them we have another
we have the most important teachable
moment a second but first let's make a
little money honey with purple mattress
purple mattress you know I love them I'm
a proselytizer for purple mattress
purple is the greatest bed I've ever
slept on purple is not quite a memory
foam it's not quite an innerspring
mattress it is this new technology was
developed by a rocket scientist it is
both hard and firm and soft at the same
time that doesn't sound like it makes
sense it does it is the best night's
sleep I've ever had I've never really
slept well I do sleep well now I just
love I can't say enough about it this
great mattress get it immediately you
won't regret it hundred night risk free
trial if you're not fully satisfied you
can return your mattress for a full
refund back by 10-year warranty free
shipping and returns you won't want to
return it you're gonna love purple right
now my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide just
text cough FAC of EF EF e two four seven
four seven four seven the only way to
get this free pillow is to text cough FA
Co V Fe Fe two four seven four seven
four seven what is it Co V Fe Fe four
seven four seven four seven message and
data rates apply the teachable moment
here for conservatives and for the
clergy is to stop being so self
aggrandizing that the defining sin
I guess the queen of all sins is pride
and it's particularly pronounced in our
time pride a vanity ego
we have pride parades not just for gay
people for everybody
we have shout your abortion pride we
have self-love we have constant self
referential tropes in our culture pride
vanity ego self aggrandizement
and that's why all these guys from the
clergy to the diocese of Covington to
the Conservatives to National Review
which thankfully took down that awful
piece it's all about pride it's all
about self aggrandizement it's about
regardless of the truth regardless of
the facts regardless of the potential
victims here it's about showing see I'm
good I'm really good I'm better than
these people I'm so good aren't I good
I'm look at me look at me look at me
that's what it's about and we should
take a break from that pride is a very
bad thing it goeth before destruction
and a haughty spirit before a fall
another teachable moment for everybody
here the fake news media are horrendous
they are horrific they'll do it to
everybody they will do this to anybody
I'll show you how they do it - been in a
second but before we cut to the break I
do want to read this is the statement
from the kid his name is gosh what is
his name Sandman I believe Nathan
Sandman Nick Nick Sam and Nathan is the
Indian guy Nick Sandman I believe is his
name this is what he wrote he sent its
in and had to run it I'll read it in
full because the media won't give this
guy airtime I am providing this factual
account of what happened on Friday
afternoon at the Lincoln Memorial to
correct misinformation and outright lies
being spread about my family and me I am
the student in the video who was
confronted by the Native American
professor I arrived at the Lincoln
Memorial at 4:30 p.m. I was told to be
there by 5:30 p.m. when our busses were
due to leave Washington for the trip
back to Kentucky
we had been attending the March for Life
rally and then had split up into small
groups to do sightseeing when we arrived
we noticed
or african-american protesters who were
also in the steps of the Lincoln
Memorial
I'm not sure what they were protesting
and I did not interact with them I did
hear them direct derogatory insults at
our school group the protesters said
hateful things they called us racists
biggests white crackers a British term
for cigarettes which is a slur for
homosexuals and incest kids they also
taunted an african-american student from
my school by telling him that we would
harvest his organs I have no idea what
that insult means but it was startling
to hear because we were being loudly
attacked and taunted in public a student
in our group asked one of our teacher
chaperones for permission to begin our
school spirit chance to counter the
hateful things that were being shouted
at our group the chants are commonly
used at sporting events they are all
positive in nature and sound like what
you would hear at any high school our
chaperone gave us permission to use our
school chants we would not have done
that without obtaining permission from
the adults in charge of our group at no
time did I hear any student chant
anything other than the school spirit
chants I did not witness or hear any
students chants build that wall or
anything hateful or racist at any time
assertions to the contrary are simply
false
our chants were loud because we wanted
to drown out the hateful comments that
were being shouted at us by the
protesters after a few minutes of
chanting the Native American protestors
who I hadn't previously noticed
approached our group the Native American
protesters had drums and were
accompanied by at least one person with
a camera the protestor everyone has seen
in the video began playing his drum as
he waded into the crowd which parted for
him I did not see anyone try to block
his path he locked eyes with me and
approached me coming within inches of my
face he played his drum the entire time
he was in my face I never interacted
with this protester I did not speak to
him I did not make any hand gestures or
other aggressive moves to be honest I
was startled and confused as to why he
had approached me we had already been
yelled at by another group of protesters
and when the second group approached I
was worried this situation was getting
out of control where adults were
attempting to provoke teenagers I
believe that by remaining motionless and
calm I was helping to defuse the
situation I realized everyone had
cameras and that perhaps a group of
adults was trying to provoke a group of
teenagers into a larger conflict I said
a silent prayer that the situation would
not get out of hand during the period of
the drumming a member
of the protesters entourage began
yelling at a fellow student that we
stole our land and that we should go
back to Europe I heard one of my fellow
students begin to respond I motioned to
my classmate and tried to get him to
stop engaging with the protester as I
was still in the mindset that we needed
to calm down tensions I never felt like
I was blocking the Native American
protester he did not make any attempt to
go around me it was clear to me that he
had singled me out for a confrontation
although I'm not sure why the engagement
ended when one of our teachers told me
the buses had arrived and it was time to
go I obeyed my teacher and simply walked
to the buses at that moment I thought I
had diffused the situation by remaining
calm and I was thankful nothing physical
had occurred I never understood why
either of the two groups of protesters
were engaging with us or exactly what
they were protesting at the Lincoln
Memorial we were simply there to meet a
bus not become central players in a
media spectacle this is the first time
in my life I've encountered any sort of
public protest let alone this kind of
confrontation or demonstration I was not
intentionally making faces at the
protester I did smile at one point
because I wanted him to know that I was
not going to become angry intimidated or
be provoked into a larger confrontation
I'm a faithful Christian and practicing
Catholic now is try to live up to the
ideals my faith teaches me to remain
respectful of others and to take no
action that would lead to conflict or
violence I harbor no ill will for this
person I respect this person's right to
protest and engage in free speech
activities and I support his chanting on
the steps of the Lincoln Memorial any
day of the week I believe he should
rethink his tactics of invading the
personal space of others but that is his
choice to make I am being called every
name in the book including a racist and
I will not stand for this mob like
character assassination of my family's
name my parents were not on the trip and
I strive to represent my family in a
respectful way in all public settings I
have received physical and death threats
via social media as well as hateful
insults one person threatened to harm me
at school and one person claims to live
in my neighborhood my parents are
receiving death and professional threats
because of the social media mob that has
formed over this issue I love my school
my teachers in my classmates I work hard
to achieve good grades and to
participate in extracurricular
activities I'm mortified that so many
people have come to believe something
that did not happen the students from my
school were chanting or acting in a
racist fashion toward African Americans
or Native Americans I did not do that do
not have hateful feelings in my heart
and did not witness any of my classmates
doing that I
cannot speak for everyone only for
myself but I can tell you my experience
with Covington Catholic is the students
are respectful of all races and cultures
we also support everyone's right to free
speech I'm not going to comment on the
words or account of mr. Phillips as I
don't know him and would not presume to
know what is in his mind or heart I'll
do that instead for him just a little
interjection nor am I going to comment
further on the other protesters as I
don't know their hearts or minds either
I have read that mr. Phillips is a
veteran of the US Marines I thanked him
for a service and I'm grateful to anyone
who defends puts on the uniform to
defend our nation if anyone has earned
the right to speak freely it's a US
Marine veteran I can only speak for
myself and what I observed and felt at
the time but I would caution everyone
passing judgment based on a few seconds
of video to watch the longer video clips
that are on the internet as they show a
much different story that is being
portrayed with by people with agendas I
provide this account of events to the
Diocese of Covington so they may know
exactly what happened and I stand ready
and willing to cooperate with any
investigation they are conducting end of
statement beautiful statement the kid
acted tremendously well and has my
absolute admiration really well done the
Diocese of Covington and many of the
clergy including father James Martin and
the Archbishop whose name escapes me at
the moment probably for the for to his
benefit and others in the conservative
movement others in the mainstream media
of course many politicians have
disappointed me tremendously it is not
that they made the mistake some people I
think made a genuine mistake that was
pushed forward by their pride and self
aggrandizement we all do this we all
make mistakes we all get it wrong
sometimes and we're all prideful so I
actually don't blame them for that I'm
not I'm not I don't mean to disparage
any of those people for having pride or
for making a mistake but where they go
wrong is that they haven't apologized
the Diocese of Covington most of the
conservative movement actually has
apologized and taken down their post
Scott Adams came out he said I'm sorry I
got a totally wrong National Review
pulled down the piece so they they
mostly did apologize Diocese of
Covington hasn't father James Martin
hasn't the archbishop has them many many
other clergy I don't mean Oh
to single them out have not apologized
they have they're sticking to their guns
despite so much exonerating evidence and
that that is a real shame that's a
scandal that is causing scandal it is
causing scandal not only in the Catholic
Church not only in the town of Covington
but throughout the mainstream media it's
why people have declining trust in
politics and in the Catholic Church and
in the mainstream media and that is what
scandal is and they are scandalizing all
of us and they should stop and they
should apologize and they should be
humble and they they'll be forgiven
that's that's a good thing about a
graceful society is you can be forgiven
but you have to instead of doubling down
or pontificating with vague and stupid
platitudes you should just apologize
because you got it wrong that's that
story they did it to bend to they did it
to Ben that he made a comment he was
asked a question at the March for Life
and I'll let you just see the clip this
is the clip that caused mayhem according
to the mainstream media finally argument
number 10 this one has become popular in
recent years after the book Freakonomics
came out that argument is that abortion
lowers the crime rate right that all the
that what has lowered the crime rate
traditionally has been killing all the
would-be criminals
first of all hey I don't know who's
comfortable with the pre-crime version
of humanity where we get to decide
before you're born whether you're likely
to be a criminal and then abort you
based on future criminal activity in
which you have not participated right
the argument I guess here is that would
you kill baby Hitler and the truth is
that no pro-life person on earth would
kill baby Hitler right because baby
Hitler wasn't Hitler adult Hitler was
Hitler maybe Hitler was a baby caused
chaos caused me does anybody disagree
with that no of course not but the
Huffington Post made this the big story
they were calling for boycotts this was
the big I'm not just cuz he's my friend
he said nothing wrong he said that is we
all would agree with that statement but
this is what they do
BuzzFeed came out bombshell story on
President Trump Trump told his lawyer to
lie to Congress they have their sources
from the Special Counsel investigation
Bob Muller the special counsel makes his
first statement in a
year to say that the BuzzFeed story is
not accurate this is what they do this
scummy fake media this is what they do
they come up with a narrative and then
they arrange facts or falsehoods to fit
that narrative that's all they do and
and it would be less egregious it you
know look the truth always gets trampled
on that we've come to expect but now in
these Covington kids put a face on it
they're trying to ruin these kids lives
to suit their sick false narrative it's
pathetic it's also Martin Luther King
Day so I want to leave on on a happy
note on a note of a real inspiration
this was the speech the last speech the
Martin Luther King gave before the night
before he was assassinated and it's it's
one of the remarkable moments in
American oratory it's my favorite moment
of his oratory and an uplifting note for
his old and on because I've been to the
mountaintop
like anybody I would like to live a long
life longevity has its place but I'm not
concerned about that now I just want to
do God's will and he's allowed me to go
up to the mountain look over and I see
the promised land
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so I'm happy tonight on the word about
anything I'm not fearing any man
I've seen the glory
get chills every time you watch it
that's our show we have a lot more to
get to we'll do it tomorrow I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
see you tomorrow the Michael gold show
is produced by Robert Sterling executive
producer Jeremy Moore senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis clever and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case production
assistant Nick Sheehan hair and makeup
is by Jesuit Vera the Michael Noel's
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19